[Music]
meet sarah
a digital artist
martin
a web developer and new father
helen busy planning her wedding
and me
i'm making this film
we have an important thing in common
we talk using electronic communication
aids
talking computers
some disabled people have no voice or
are very difficult to understand
this does not mean we have nothing to
say
we can communicate using alternative and
agmentative communication or aac
with voice output communication aids the
synthesized voice can speak our words
most communication aids are touchscreen
computers with an integrated speaker
messages are created with a keyboard
on-screen alphabet or symbol-based
software
but many of us have limited hand
function so we have to find alternatives
we might use a switch controlled by the
hand head or foot
i use vibrations from my throat
the computer scans through options until
a selection is made with the switch in
recent years eye gaze technology has
allowed many people
to control a communication aid using eye
movement
checked by a carefully calibrated camera
the same technology can also provide
independent control of the home
environment and anything done on a
computer from film editing to grocery
shopping
[Music]
early synthesized speech sounded
somewhat robotic and offered limited
choice of voices
today a wide range of accents and
characteristics are available although
some people keep the voices they have
always used
stephen hawking chose not to update his
voice because it was so well known and
had become part of his identity
now voice banking is becoming more
accessible and affordable
someone whose speaking voice will soon
be lost can record words and phrases
from which the sounds of their voice can
be replicated on a computer
people who have never been able to speak
can invite a family member or friend
to be a voice donor
technology for talking is increasingly
individualized
[Music]
talking with a computer is not easy
switch access and eye gaze are tiring
it takes intense concentration
but often the biggest challenge is the
attitude of others
it takes me a long time to compose a
message some people walk away before i
finish
because they get bored or think i'm
incapable of responding
we are often disregarded or patronized
by people who do not recognize that we
have something to contribute if they
give us time to respond
technology for talking can seem slow and
frustrating but it allows us to express
our ideas work
create and form relationships
[Music]
sarah ezekiel creates beautiful art
using eye gaze technology
pastorius as memoir goes boy topped the
new york times bestseller list
helen quiller helps run a national
charity supporting disabled children
and i'm jemima hughes a filmmaker and
animator
we don't have speaking voices but we
lead for creative lives
technology gives us a voice
and enables us to participate
so next time you meet someone who talks
with a communication aide don't be shy
if you give us time to answer you'll
find we have something to say
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video